dinner parties can be hell the pressure
to perform when in the kitchen means
menus are often safe or stuck in a time
warp I tend to a three-course meal
starts off with prawn cocktail spaghetti
bolognaise and then we tented for frozen
dessert chocolate gateau to cook a nice
meal and be adventurous you need to have
time to be able to do that and at the
moment I just don't have the time to do
that
Carol's been cooking like this for 13
years I'm here to show her a dinner
party menu that can be done in under 30
minutes
[ __ ] chefs nightmare that looks like
cat food in there what is that run me
through the spagbol spag bol pasta yep
big itchy
mince run me through your bolognese
sauce that is my Bolognese
what do you mean that's it the tinder
jar sauce onion special onions vegetable
with garlic now it's straight onto the
spaghetti 13 years Carol three months
fine but 13 years cooking the same old
[ __ ] that let's start off with that in
there that's in there yeah we're gonna
do three dishes salmon chicken and a
cheesecake they can be done easily
whilst you get ready and lay the tail at
the same time right first of all we're
gonna do the salmon is on my menu of the
restaurant perfect for summer very very
light and the ladies dish so we'll get
the marinade done first they're spring
onions why doing that I'll chop the
chili and the nice thing about this it
can vary you know chopped ginger in
there is you a little bit more
adventurous I'd like to think of the
next 13 years that's exactly what I do
at finely chopped coriander the juice of
one lemon olive oil sesame oil and soy
sauce now that is the most difficult
part done all right and it's quick to do
that then is make a pong copter
don't dress the salmon with a mound aid
yet put it in the fridge and start the
main course chicken a simple dish with
chicken creme fraiche and capers the
outside of the pan first that's really
nice not everything will go in here so
there's no key and the pan I need to
know do we have one hand one pain when
he gets home here when you've got color
on both sides add some white wine after
2 minutes take out the garlic and
rosemary and put some capers in chicken
stock
creme fraiche in bring up the ball have
you that straightforward
it's so quick quicker than polonaise the
beauty of this chicken dish is that you
can leave it to finish while you lay the
table one last time at a cheesecake time
for dessert a no-bake cheesecake sugar
3/4 whip the cream just taste that now
with a vanilla in there lovely
I've got vanilla cream - the cream
cheese mix next creme de cassis a black
currant liqueur I know you girls like
several things cheesecake has to be
long-winded but look now why is that
[ __ ] gutter right okay you've land
right
this menu is so quick cows even had time
to get changed before her guests arrived
oh yeah and I'll get ladies in and set
down these are poor cocktail girls come
in come in come in come in nice to see
you
why did her nicely oh Jesus pistol round
the calendar girls right take a seat
there's no pong cocktail there is though
no yeah I don't think they'll be upset
do you ladies good to see you so about
the pong cocktail but they're gone
another 13 years for another one up and
pour and with her skin being removed
from underneath the salmon the pin bones
come out a lot easier